excusez écouter aujourd'hui je veux
qu'il n'y ait plus aucun secret entre
nous que vous sachiez tous deux mois
vous m'avez vu petit vous m'avez vu nu
non ça non enfin bref vous savez presque
tout ce qu'il ya à savoir sur moi il est
vrai sauf trois petits trucs que je vous
ai jamais dévoilé et qui en plus de ça
sont deux gros dossiers
c'est parti on commence tout de suite
avec ma toute première chaîne youtube
qui s'appelle dofus bouclier où je dors
chez dofus quand j'avais 12 ans et
d'ailleurs ça marche et hyper bien parce
que j'avais zéro abonnés et j'ai quand
même fait 779 vue sur la première et
1900 sur la deuxième s'il vous plaît
c'était assez ton [ __ ] ça nous
rajeunit pas attention ça commence il
vous fait quoi mettre ça en grand tout
bouge déjà ya des détails assez
incroyable hormis ces transitions qui
vient de windows movie maker et ce
nombre de cabasse très faible que
j'avais toujours été pauvres dans les
jeux aux âges de réagir mon équipement
voyez c'est ça intéresse tout le monde
ici présents à moi le premier ouais âge
raté il y avait déjà des feuilles de
montal j'avais un petit desu black
n'était pas du tout prévu à mon dieu je
tape a été un bateau qu'on attend
j'avais juste 3 images par seconde quoi
annonce marc de connexion là c'est
vraiment le bois qui ramait à mort
c'était sur windows xp bordel donc en
fait je vais je lance juste plein de
sorts différents pour montrer combien je
tape ça ça mais est ce qu'on s'en fout
est ce qu'on s'en bat les couilles
surtout avant j'étais nul à chier dans
ce jeu où personne n'était pas du tout
fort d'aller 5 images par seconde là en
2015 il passe pas du tout quoi mais ça
va regarder ma vidéo remerciement
particulier à le pool chez gide à
l'humour très drôle ça c'est du grand
humour mcgill damon soyez après je pense
qu'ils auraient préféré que j'ai site
pas à mon avis et à vous tous
ouais oh c'est quoi cette image
pixelisée à ça je me souviens on pouvait
faire des sorte d'avatar sur un site l'a
prévu pour comme ça tu parais c'est
hyper fort puissant et ou alors qu'en
vrai dans le jeu c'est une énorme merde
pour eva ça commence en beauté un
premier dossier voilà il est bien passé
ça vous a plu ou pas du tout donc ça
c'est un mois plus tard on la transition
est un peu mieux de gérer un petit
progrès il est vrai la relève psa
toujours pas celle d'un pc je monte mon
équipements tout le monde s'en bat
royalement les specs mais c'est pas
grave je fais quand même même même pas
de repas j'avais pas vu je fais une
vidéo avec 560 cammas
r je me souviens pas de grand-chose mais
je me souviens que ça c'est une somme
totalement ridicule c'est vraiment je
vais être le jour le plus pauvre du jeu
voit accuser mon reproche de continuer
de voir cette superbe vidéo
mais avant d'en arriver là j'ai dû xv et
il y avait une petite histoire un
scénario ok j'ai aussi drop quelques
trucs aulas pour finalement atteindre
mon but t'as jamais une vie palpitante à
l'époque aux mondiaux il est toujours à
trois images seconde
samedi le stop elle a ensuite y'a quoi
c'est toujours utile dans la première on
fait tellement à des jolies des filles à
des défis au hockey j'ai tué quelqu'un
par aman ouais mais je comprends plus
rien c'est incroyable heil et des
guildes et d'ail fesman est blasé
j'arrivais déjà à l'époque à faire chier
des gens le chieur éternel merci d'avoir
regardé ma vidéo merci à ma guilde nommé
art il faut que tu apprennes à de
publicité tu leur fais honte
merci à vous d'avoir regardé ma deuxième
vidéo elle était super lucas ok on est
bon pour ces deux premiers dossiers mais
en fait si vous savez pas c'est que j'ai
eu une deuxième chaîne youtube avant la
troisième qui est celle ci se vidéo bc2
alors membre depuis novembre 2010 donc c
est environ 5 ans presse rouge avait
cartonné
j'avais 50 abonnés donc cette fois
c'était sur bad company 2 battlefield 3
était pas encore sorti et oui moi qui
joue à bad company 2 sur arica harbor en
match à mort par squad aulas je vais te
donner un petit style anglais je voulais
percer manière internationale
ouais ça commence grenade weck est jolie
qu'il holosko [ __ ] de vie hyper loin
et je pensais pas l'avoir assez distant
donc de l arrivée mômes dans les notes
allant fois excès après j'ai auger la
saq après j'ai eu envie de me défoncer
un peu trop soit 720 assez la fin on en
termine sur ça mais c'est finalement
c'était juste une petite mise en bouche
avant le vrai montage en chine mais
j'avais deux gemmes porte c'est un
scandale et 3 commentaires ok analysons
ça tu joues en mode hardcore égale le
mode des noobs tu utilises quand même
les munitions magnum même en mode
hardcore conclusion toi égal nous menons
mais juste une vidéo comme ça pour le
plaisir
j'ai jamais voulu être vulgaire août au
fond si je comprends pas bon rien dans
cette foutue vidéo à la fin oh ça
commence bien
hop là après c'est juste un seul qu'il
mais je l'aimé tout d'affilée quoi il ya
stockés dans une oreille on est d'accord
au l'effet casas avait pris un max de
temps je me souviens mon gars juste pris
trois heures ni à faire ça on ralentit
dans son costard
ah je crois que ça c'était un truc style
est par contre moi un à y avait du lag
un [ __ ] quand je tire statut mais que
va-t-on après attention - 2 c'est beau
en fait c'est comme dans battlefield à
l'époque turin paraissait sur la mecque
des tâches quad est donc clair appareil
succédant sur les oat et moi je me
régale voilà c'est le festa joué que
quatre ont fait sur sa à tanger us tiré
sur un drôle de voir ce qu'est le droit
ni faisait la taille d'un camion qui
volent quoi oh il ya une collatéral
excusez moi j'étais en train de dormir
on y avait déjà fait une collatéral oh
oh oh
bosco petros pape une fois de plus de
très très loin j'ai pas vu à temps j'ai
pété le toit etc un mortier et regardez
le lui en position foetale lille et qui
se croient cash et j'ai eu le but est ou
pas donc il a toujours pas compris
allez au revoir bonus ah on me dit du c4
sous les véhicules des copains choc le
véhicule s'envoler très très loin même
avec les temps qui me semble que ça
marche et le aux archers moyens quoi mec
est mort brûlé à part ça eh bien il
respecte une voilà donc j'ai obtenu 49
abonnés grâce à ces deux là et puis bah
peut-être un seul abonnés grâce à celle
là qui était mon père alors je
maintenant le contexte un enfant venait
d'avoir deux ans voilà et je lui
souhaiter bon anniversaire à fait à
cette vidéo voilà donc c'est ce qu'on
appelle du stop motion donc je proclame
photos et jeux d'ea ligne et ça fait une
sorte de petite vidéo pas aussi fluide
que mon gameplay sur depuis tout à
l'heure quoi à elle s'en va par la porte
wahou attendait ce que j'ai vu en file
serait ce monsieur au char c'est photo
par photo sur une photo cm pas y
appuyait les grandes jantes de mon père
louis de lights grandes jambes dont je
n'ai pas hérité d'ailleurs pourquoi je
suis petit papa dit moi toi tu es grand
bond à lacets sont les bêtises c'est la
fin de cette troisième vidéo attend sur
le meilleur pour la fin
on est maintenant sur mon tout premier
skyblog ward et sarlat c'est vraiment
qu'ils couland je peux malheureusement
pas vous donner le nom parce qu'il ya
des photos d'autres personnes que moi
est bon il faut un peu les respecter
elles n'ont pas forcément envie de
s'afficher comme moi et c'est parti
régalons nous et voilà mon frère avec sa
grosse touffe de merde d'avant [ __ ]
pardon fleuron le dos mais c'est parce
que tu crois que j'étais un ado mondial
gt1 foetus quoi j'avais 9 ans et je
serais pour faire des connards comme ça
et là rien fait mais maintenant rassurez
vous il est beaucoup plus beau aller
lâche toi ta main street est stable
dessus aulas genre de truc nul alors
qu'est ce qu'ils disaient les gens
audrey le trois quarts c'est vrai le
quatre-quarts j'ai envie de leur faire
quoi at en 2007 j'avais 10 ans là on
parlera pas la même chose pas possible
c'est quoi le leucate c'est quoi tout
autant si ça ne dérangerait pas de
sortir avec moi messieurs on dirait
carrément que c'est ce à quoi je pense
c'est pas possible j'avais 10 ans g
affluent déjà mais on doit se tromper on
doit se tromper ça devait être un smack
alors ou à une nomade qui se sont
effleurés un jour moi je tape 7 3 8 et 3
sympa lucas même si on traîne pas trop
ensemble
ok pour aller à plus mon pote je ne me
souviens d'aucun tony dans ma vie donc
je trouve que cet homme est un imposteur
je le connais paquet l'agilité des
doigts alors lui franchement faire ça
avec les doigts c'est trop chaud je
rêvais de faire ça vraiment pour pas à
l'époque c'était trop le 3 classe
finalement c'est un peu comme avoir une
mercedes classe c où je mettais en
avance sur mon skyblog mes talents pour
la gymnastique car grâce à sa sortie
avec beaucoup de filles aucune cette
photo c'est une oeuvre d'art à droite
mon amoureuse c'est celle qui est trop
belle lol et à gauche ma meilleure amie
c'est gentil de dire ça pour ta
meilleure amie réducteur que moi ils
veulent prendre qu'elles sont belles
surtout toi audrey audrey celle de
droite les deux plus belles filles du
monde vous êtes trop belle surtout toi
voudrait la pomme munichois julie tu
étais belle gosse qu'on avait dix ans tu
en fais pas c'est mon frère qui fait un
salto avant mais il est super fort
huawei florine houmadi donc ça va tu es
tout bon comme ça tu as c'est vraiment
laid le royaume de kikoo quoi même si
mes parents sont divorcés snif je vois
mon père un week-end sur deux mais
samsung de le voir qu'un week end sur
deux je veux le voir plus souvent aux
pignons et bokassa numérique que moi mon
père et ma ni donné sa virilité ni ses
grandes jambes qu il était après qu il a
profité de coller sur mon front avec
deux adresses msn dessus c'est pas
magnifique ça n'ont clairement pas et à
l'époque je pense que je me trouvais
stylet sur cette photo il n'y avait pas
encore photoshop à l'époque donc le seul
moyen de s'embellir maintenance et
photoshop tu mets un peu un peu
d'humidité up à l'époque tu prenais un
groupe aussi tu le mets tu es là voilà
ça te faisait beau gosse je suis un
monstre c'était à la super soirée
n'aurait dans la salle de la disco il y
avait des trucs qui faisait que tous
ceux qui étaient blancs d'oeuf des
blancs fluorescence des trop marrant
kikoolol kikoolol qui cookies colloque
et audrey du manque trop même si je te
vois tous les jours ok tu pensais à
séduire en faisant ça lui casser ça
c'est pour ça que ça a mal fini lui
qu'un prêt n'est pas dire des choses
comme ça et oui je suis un ouf des
sceaux ce soit là est pourri mais ma
posant les restes il est papa tellement
lucas sauter d'une chaise en plastique
et une autre chaise en plastique c'est
ce passé où ça c'est moi a une super
fête de noël à la photo de la louve
regarder le plaisir dans ce regard
le total aux accents et les on dit quoi
plutôt n'y a pas d'ambiance à ta soirée
ou quoi envier aux miennes après tu me
diras c'est là qu'elle l'a mieux rdv le
28 mai pour madoff d'anniv je t'invite
avec toute la famille et vas-y elle
était très bien la soirée 1
ceci tu te prends pour qui là et tu te
fais trop là où fin et c'est déjà la fin
de ce qu'elle obtint j'aurais aimé
qu'ils encore 28 pages quoi c'est
tellement amusant et bien écoutez
j'espère ça nous a plu et si les cas
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo comme
d'habitude bon je pensais vous a plu
vous êtes friands de ce genre de
conneries à quelqu'un tu me lis comme ça
sur internet ça vous plaît un merci
d'avoir regardé n'hésitez pas à balancer
le lien dans vos anciens skyblog que moi
aussi je rigole un peu
merci d'avoir gardé on se retrouve très
bientôt dans cette prochaine vidéo audio
tout le monde puisse